i can't wait to have your band do this
song because this is one of my favorite
rolling stone songs we're talking about
live with me what do you love so much
about this song first and foremost i
love that i have this memory that goes
along with it when mick called me
i hadn't really exploded yet but there
was a big buzz and i was in france and
he called in the middle of the night my
manager said i think you're going to get
a call from mick jagger's management and
he called
and then i and i was like yeah so i get
over there and i see keith and keith's
like hey little sister so you're gonna
do live with me
and i was like
sure sure and i'm like oh my god how's
it go how's it going i got to remember
and so you know
i just have this incredible memory of
being thrown into
the big boys club the real rock star
circus well here's sheryl crow with live
with me a rolling stones cover i'm very
excited about
[Music]
i got nasty habits
[Music]
don't you think there's a place for you
there between the sheets
don't you wanna live with me
[Music]
century
don't you think we need a woman's touch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't you wanna live with me
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
don't you think there's a place for us
[Applause]
right across the street
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love that
i like when you and uh when you and jen
starts harmonizing together
no that's really great do that acapella
for me please do it you you and jen the
score they have brain children they're
all locked in the nursery
they got earphone heads they got dirty
next to so 20 century
well they queue up for the bathroom
round about
7 35
don't you think we need a woman's touch
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow she sounds good right